people have been calling apple's 14 and
16 inch macbook pros the best laptops
ever made and we just got some new
bombshell leaks pointing to apple
updating these systems sooner and even
better than a lot of people are
expecting and i'm gonna dig into all
those leaks and my reasoning for why
these new macbook pros are gonna have
three nanometer chips yes three
nanometer not five nanometer like a lot
of people are expecting and i'm gonna
prove it to you in this video now it all
starts with mark german who is by far
the most reliable apple leaker out there
he has a ton of leaks and an 86.5
accuracy rating for those leaks now
recently he tweeted out that apple's
september event is happening on
september 7th with new iphones and
devices coming out on september 16th now
within the actual article itself from
bloomberg he did say that it's looking
like apple is going to be launching new
macs before the end of the year as it
works on versions of the mac mini and
macbook pro with m2 based processors and
he is of course talking about the higher
end 14 and 16 inch macbook pros which a
while back he showed that they're gonna
have 12 core cpu and for sure 38 cores
for the gpu as well as the mac mini and
back in july last month he did say that
the m2 pro and m2 max macbook pros are
expected between fall 2022 and spring
2023 which is what i initially thought i
thought it's going to be coming in
spring because they're on an 18 month
cycle and that's of course because the
m2 macbook air came 18 months after the
first m1 macbook air and i think apple's
gonna follow the same cycle but check
out this bombshell leak that we just got
we literally just got this the other day
three nanometer m2 pro chip for the
macbook pro is reportedly entering
production
later this year that's from taiwan's
commercial times yes they said it's
three nanometer not five nanometer and
if we dig in even closer to 95 max
article it says the report suggests
apple's m2 pro chip will be the first
product to feature this three nanometer
technology yes the first one and it's
going to be available in the second half
of this year now this is mind-blowing
because i thought that if it is getting
three nanometer it's going to be getting
delayed until the spring but apparently
we can have both because a lot of people
were saying it's coming this year with
five nanometer but imagine if it's both
earlier
and
faster with three nanometer and speaking
of getting things done faster have you
ever needed to convert video files into
a different mac or windows format well
we've been converting video files for
years now using wondershare's incredibly
fast and optimized unit converter app
which now supports high speed conversion
with both lossless and gpu accelerated
conversion making it much faster than
regular conversion and unit converter
can also compress over a thousand video
and audio formats into smaller file
sizes without losing much quality at all
plus it's got some new ai lab features
as well so check out unit converter 14
by using the link in the description
below and now getting back to the video
the whole three nanometer thing is not
an old rumor because shrimp apple pro
did talk about it and he actually
replied to the tweet from nine to five
mac talking about the three nanometer
chip production with this kind of cool
face with glasses saying that like yes i
got this leak right because earlier
months ago in june he did say that
people keep believing that any three
nanometer soc or chip will be of the m3
series but no he says the m2 pro and max
will get three nanometer that was back
in june and along with that he also said
i don't know where people think three
nanometer will be for only the m3 which
is not going to come out in 18 months
and not for the m2 and pro max so he's
implying that yes the m2 pro and the max
are getting three nanometer as well now
back in june on 27th after he talked
about that we got a leak from digi times
saying that the upcoming m2 pro chip is
gonna be on
nanometer including for the mac mini as
well and then going back even further
june 7th we had a report from jeff poo
saying that tsmc is starting mass
production of new three nanometer m2 pro
chip later this year and he was correct
because we did get those reports a
couple of days ago saying that tsmc is
beginning three nanometer chip
production next month in september so
jeff poo was right about the three
nanometer chip production now if we
actually look at what tsmc themselves
were saying they said that tsmc's first
three nanometer class node is called n3
and is on track to start high volume
manufacturing in the second half of this
year actual chips are said to be
delivered to customers in early 2023
this technology is mostly aimed at early
adopters read apple and the like who can
invest in leading-edge designs and would
benefit from the performance power area
advantages offered by leading edge nodes
so apple's going to be basically the
first customer and yes that was
confirmed earlier this morning apple's
going to be the first to use tsmc's
three nanometer process which means they
gotta have some kind of products coming
sooner than later which is why i think
it might even be possible to come later
this year but more likely in the spring
and the main reason for that is because
intel's 14 gen meteor lake was supposed
to get some three nanometer node parts
from tsmc to put into their integrated
gpu but no it was dropped because intel
is delaying those chips until 2024
most likely so intel is no longer going
to be using tsmc's three nanometer node
production and that's why apple is going
to be taking advantage of that now along
with that we actually got a pretty
interesting leak from the forum user on
mac rumors moissanite and he gave us
some crazy information about the higher
end m2 chips going into the 14 and
16-inch macbook pro and mac mini from a
friend with early access to a prototype
now he says apple is currently testing
two models of these chips one is gonna
have a 12 core cpu with three nanometer
yes three nanometer there's going to be
eight high performance cores two middle
performance yes because this new finfet
technology has three different
optimizations for the actual three
nanometer cores themselves so two middle
and then two high efficiency cores as
well so this is going to be really
interesting and apple's probably going
to make a big deal in terms of the
marketing now he says that this version
on three nanometer is going to be 10
faster than the other m2 pro and max
version while being 35
more efficient as well which is crazy
and he says if this is going to be the
final m2 pro chip model then apple's
going to announce it sometime in march
or april 2023 which is 18 months after
this 16 inch macbook pro came out with
the m1 pro and m1 max and that totally
makes sense and it lines up what i think
and it also lines up with tsmc's own
timelines now the other m2 pro chip
model is based on the regular m2 that we
have now with eight high performance
cores and four high efficiency cores
with the n5p five nanometer process the
same as the m2 and if that's the final
model then it's going to be announced
and come sometime in november
2022. now he did say that the gpu is
going to be a 20 core for the m2 pro and
the m2 max is going to have a 40 core
which is going to be awesome he said
that there is going to be bend models
like a 30 core for the m2 max and a 16
core for the m2 pro and that makes sense
but he also says that it's going to have
a better media encoding decode engine
than the m1 pro and max and it's going
to have 300 gigabytes per second memory
bandwidth for the m2 pro and 600 for the
m2 max and the apple is not working on
the m2 ultra yet
and he said the mac mini is only going
to get the optional m2 pro option while
the 14 and 16 inch will get the m2 pro
and the m2 max so that makes sense in
terms of those leaks now the reason why
i think apple is going to go with a
three nanometer option of the m2 pro and
m2 max is because i don't think the 5
nanometer version is gonna cut it and
the reason for that is because we tested
the 24 core versus the 32 core gpu m1
max chip within the 14 inch macbook pro
and we discovered that the 14 inch
thermal throttles like crazy even with
the m1 max chip as you can see right
here the 32 core version within the 14
inch chassis is slower
than the 16 inch 24 core version so even
though you have a faster gpu with more
cores it was actually slower because of
thermal throttling so it's basically
using too much power that's causing too
much heat within the 14 inch chassis and
the reason that matters is because we've
been testing the m2 chip in the macbook
pro and we discovered that the m2 chip
uses 33
more power on average than the m1 while
in a cinebench run and that only led to
13
more actual score or performance so
basically the m2 chip is overclocked to
the max using a bunch of extra power to
try to squeeze out more performance now
imagine if that 14 inch is already
thermal throttling and then apple
upgrades it to the five nanometer
overclocked version of the m2 pro that's
gonna use even more power and it's gonna
thermal throttle even more than it
already is right now and i don't think
apple is gonna be okay with that they're
gonna try to make the three nanometer
chip work as much as they possibly can
and then to add another reason the final
one i actually did an interview with
mark german and he talked about what he
expects for the m2 pro and m2 max 14 and
16 inch macbook pros and he says he does
not expect the design to change at all
he said it's mainly going to be a chip
swap and maybe some internal specs are
going to get upgraded and that's it so
if apple is not going to change anything
about the features or design they're
just gonna upgrade the chip mainly i
don't think the five nanometer version
of the m2 pro and m2 max is gonna cut it
i don't think so i don't think it's
gonna be that much faster i think apple
needs the marketing of the first three
nanometer chip to make that very popular
and to get people to upgrade to those
new macbook pros so because of that i am
almost 100 sure that these new m2 pro
and m2 max chips are gonna be on tsmc's
three nanometer process
and that is going to make them a whole
lot better than a lot of people are
expecting and that's why you should
probably wait if you're considering
buying one of these and you actually
have time to wait you probably should so
if you totally disagree with me let me
know down in the comment section below
but if you enjoyed this video click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]